Jim Jordan just came out and demands IRS
explained unannounced visit to Matt
taibi's home this is a National Review
story Jim Jordan sent a letter to
treasurer secretary Janet Yellen Iris
commissioner Daniel warful asking for an
explanation as to why federal agents
were sent to mataibi South on the same
day he appeared before the select
subcommittee on the weaponization of the
federal government which was chaired by
Jordan Tybee informed Jordan that the
IRS instructed him to contact the agency
four days later and he was told about
his 2018 and 2021 tax filings were
requested due to concerns over identity
theft Tybee shared his 2018 tax
submissions with the select committee
which showed no problems was registered
with the tax return for more than four
and a half years taibi shared a new
information revealing Twitter
censorships industrial complex which
showed the social media's platform
worked with federal agencies and ngos to
censor or downplay posts they found
objectionable now objectionable how much
of it is is just ironic coincidental how
much of this we think was intentional
it's totally intentional everything that
we have happening in this government
right now is purposeful and intentional
uh that's my big concern is the
censorship issue that's my big concern
about going after people and trying to
instill that fear and weaponizing
federal government agencies uh they can
do it better if if you're disarmed but
why don't you just send an email
I mean ask a guy about you know whatever
this identity issue is why are you
showing up at his house the day that
he's in Washington DC you're sending a
message I mean that's what Mafia does
okay that's what gangs do to send a
message that's what the clan used to do
burning crosses you know in the front
yard so this government that we have
right now Patrick this is the thing that
scares me the most it reminds me of the
East German Stasi police
where all of a sudden if you're a
pro-life activist an advocate you end up
in jail if you're Jane's Revenge that is
going out and firebombing you know
pro-life pregnancy centers and attacking
churches and vandalizing churches
nothing happens to you
if you're just a person that's walking
through the capitol on January 6 you're
a felon you're in jail if you're antifa
that shows up and you shoot at police
officers and burn down government
buildings and everything nothing happens
to you as a matter of fact we're going
to raise money to help you to make the
bail
so there's a two-tier system of justice
that is going on here and again it comes
back that's what the left does to its
opposition
the left does not want opposition they
want to instill you talk about fear they
want to instill fear in you that says if
you stand up to us we're going to get
you 87 000 new IRS agents what do you
think that means it's gonna be a lot
more people coming around and paying
visits to folks and Matt taibi is no
conservative he's no maggot whatsoever
but you actually more libertarian
actually left-leaning liberal they made
him one now yeah of course that's what's
gonna happen yeah yeah and by the way we
need more investigative journalists so
shout out to my table for doing the hard
work that he does so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]